Oh, well it's Saroj and I've got sand
between my cheeks. Feels really weird.
Check out this pine cone
that I found on the way.
Here are eight sets of clockwise spirals.
While there are 13 sets of
counterclockwise spirals,
when we divide 13 bikey,
the answer is 1.6 better
known as the golden ratio.
The golden ratio is all around us.
It's in the curvature of the ocean waves,
it's in seashells,
it's in the spiral that makes up our milky
way galaxy from a simple set of rules
and were just enormous complexity
and the universe works this way.
Our brains must as well.
We're going to create our own universe
simulation in 60 lines of python
in 1970 and article was
published in scientific
American about a game created by
a mathematician named John
Conway called the game of life.
Conway was interested in a problem
presented by the computer scientist,
von Neumann,
von Neumann theorize of a type of machine
that could build copies of itself.
He called the universal constructor.
This machine would be useful
for colonizing other planets.
We could theoretically send this machine
to Mars before humans and it could mine
and smelt iron in order to make more
copies of itself and soon an army of these
could help develop an atmosphere before
humans arrived or it's like independence.
Then only Wellsmith could save us.
Welcome to Mars.
He based it off a concept he
called cellular automaton or ca.
The idea behind [inaudible] is that the
behavior of a group can be described by
the interactions between a simple machine
or automaton and you're by identical
automaton that interact with it. In the
game of life, the universe is infinite.
Two dimensional grid of squares cells.
Each cell can be one of two states,
either alive or dead and every cell
interacts with its eight neighbor sells
their just for rules to the game.
Any lifestyle with less than two live
neighbors dies up loneliness and you live
cell with two or three live neighbors
lives on to the next generation or
survives any lives saw with more
than three live neighbors dies of
overpopulation and lively.
Any dead cell with exactly three live
neighbors becomes a lifestyle as if by
reproduction.
Once you say your initial configuration
of cells on the grid and start the game,
complex patterns will start to emerge.
We just,
those four rules like the eater which
eats all sorts of organisms or a breeder
which grows its number of
life cells faster and faster
or gliders and spaceships
and really crazy gigantic ecosystems
that become more complex with time.
Yo. Okay, let's build our own command line
version of the game of life. In Python.
We just have to libraries to import both
CIS and terminal well that it's input
data and read it from terminal.
Let's get right into the main method,
but we will implement
our high level code well.
First one I defined our grit universe.
Get term side is a function that returns
the host terminals within height.
Once we have those two values,
we can format her grid so that
it fits into our terminal.
The grid will be a two dimensional array.
Now that we have our grid defined,
we can try it on the screen
with the update screen function,
which will update the terminal to display
it with a set of ones and Zeros for
each cell.
That cells will be white zeros in
living cells will be read once the Greg,
we'll start off with all dead cells,
so we'll want to set our initial
living cells. Once we set these,
they will evolve within the simulation
while abiding by the four simple rules we
talked about earlier,
the read initial configuration function.
It takes the grid as a perimeter and we'll
ask the user to input the coordinates
of their living cells to start the game.
Once we have our initial
configuration set,
we'll need to know how many
iterations to play the game,
so we'll ask a user for that number.
We'll set an iteration step variable to
keep track of which iteration we're on.
Then update the screen
to show our user input.
It's structures will then create a while
loop that will run for the length of
the game. Inside of our while loop,
we'll create a variable called play,
which will represent the user input.
Either the number of steps
remaining or the quit input,
but don't quit because we're,
if the user types in quit,
we'll break the loop and the game is over.
We will code a try except block to
convert the string input to an integer for
the number of steps and set them to one.
If there is an exception,
then we'll start our for loop for
each step defined by the user.
That means that each time step we're
going to apply the four rules to what's on
the screen until the total
number of iterations is over.
We'll create a new grid that will
store the original grades. Next step.
The next step function
will help us do this.
Let's take a look at that
function in more detail.
It's got a nested for loop in it. This is
where we're going to take our old grid,
apply our four rules to it and store
the result and the updated grill.
It's a nested for loops.
Since we're going to go through every
single cell and the grid matrix to apply
our four rules to each of them at each
of these cells will need to count the
number of live cells around it,
which is what the healthy
neighbors function looks
for. It takes our grid and x,
y coordinates as its parameters.
The live neighbors variables
stores are number of live cells.
Once we have that number,
we can apply our four rules in the
case that our current cell is alive,
any lifestyle with fewer than two live
neighbors dyes as it caused by under
population and any lifestyle with more
than three live neighbors dies as if I
overpopulation. The end result for
both of these cases is a dead cell,
so we can set our current
self to zero or dead.
If either of these is the case else,
it lives since that is our third rule.
Any live cell with exactly two or three
live neighbors lives on to the next
generation. That leads our last
rule, which is four dead cells.
Any dead cell with exactly three
live neighbors, he comes alive.
Sal as if by reproduction, uh, sex.
So we'll send it to alive so that we'll
place our new cell states in the new
grid.
Once we have this new grid,
we'll set it to the original grid and
the new grade where we said to the
original grid,
they switched values.
We can then update the screen to
show the state of our updated grid.
When our loop finishes,
we'll update our iteration step
variable to include the number of steps,
the user input,
and that'll be the end of our wild loop
will run on a script by typing in python
life.py. We'll be able to see
our initial Greg with no values.
I'm going to create two
small glider organisms that
will move through the space.
I'll type in this set of coordinates
for each of them for each.
Then when I'm ready, I'll
say, let's run this thing for
1000 iterations. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've got links for you in the
description and definitely subscribe.
If you want to see more programming
videos, I've got to go create a universe,
so thanks for watching.